hey guys what's up this is eric gnom and
i'm back here today at buzzfeed to rank
my songs i hate it actually it's like
picking your favorite child i know your
parents may have a favorite child mine
don't at least that's what they tell me
but the cruel cruel vicious people at
buzzfeed are making me choose my
offspring
and rank them just vicious i just want
to preface this by saying all these
songs are absolute fire this is not of
all time this is just today how i feel
it's going to change all the time all
right here we go
[Music]
and we start with the doozies i also
love that you guys literally pitted all
the new ones like my most recent
favorite ones against each other i don't
know you anymore in any other way are
the first two singles off my new album i
wanted all of these to get to the final
four but you're just making me kill them
from the very get-go
it's just savage internally like it's
any other way
then i look at the numbers and i look at
the streams and i think of i think of
you the viewer and my fans nomination we
are a community we are a family and the
streams on i don't know you anymore are
just like freaking taken off so i'm
gonna go with i don't know you anymore
but any other way is still great it's a
really good song it has this addictive
whistle in it it's beautiful god damn it
the next one is lost on me and wildfire
who said this is okay [ __ ] up i'm
sorry
but we can't curse lost tommy is the new
single off my album my album is called
there back again it's out now and it's
an incredible album wildfire is like
this haunting beautiful song with an
incredible drop moment but lost on me is
the single for the album which is why
i'm here at buzzfeed to promote the
album let's call it what it is okay so i
feel like i have to go with lost on me
next up what if and admit oh we're just
really tearing apart my new album what
if it's more of like a retro fun what if
we never broke up kind of thing and
admit is like cold air you have a jacket
on and you're driving somewhere you're
by yourself and you just like reminisce
and you just get really emotional and
that's what admit is aren't you curious
yeah you should go stream ah man they're
both really good today it's cold weather
it's frigid air and so admit winds next
up is one way lover and come through one
way lover is a song that kevin garrett
took part in writing and come through is
off my first full-length album called
before we began come through is like a
classic for me one more level it will
become a classic but right now to me in
this moment come through with singing my
name so i want to come through
i've been looking for you oh sheesh guys
literally just you should have put some
like bad songs in here oh wait i don't
have bad songs
love daiyoung and congratulations both
singles off of my first english ep i'm
going to go with love diahyun
congratulations it's a solid song with
marky basie love dai young really just
took off with a life and legs of its own
in being a very emotional song and
probably one of my most personal songs
that i've ever written next up we have
you're sexy i'm sexy yes i have a song
called you're sexy i'm sexy and a lot of
people laugh but when you hear it you
realize damn i'm sexy it's a very
encouraging song you should listen to it
how am i doing is a sad song and right
now i feel sexy so we're gonna go with
you sexy i'm sexy and then it's wonder
and trouble with you these are so
different both of these songs were
written in nashville wonder is like
you're in bed at night and you wonder if
trouble with you it's just like a fun
love song i do think wonder is much more
of a heartstring puller so let's say
wonder here's another doozy honestly
verse paradise look as much as i love
paradise i think we're gonna go with
honestly because it was representative
of such a big pivotal moment in my music
career a classic there we go we've
knocked out eight songs let's go knock
out eight more ooh okay how you been and
down for you
down for you i just performed it live
for the first time a few months ago at
music midtown my dancers came up with a
really fun dance for it there's a body
roll hip thrust air guitar spinach
spoilage and that's what i just thought
of run away versus i don't miss you
that's tough
run away these are all just classics
ocean and this is not a love song
potion it makes you want to party it
makes you want to take a shot at tequila
and maybe loosen a piece of clothing i'm
not telling you to i'm just telling you
that's how it feels it's about having a
good time and then it's lose you and
don't call me
should we be emotional or should we say
f you think i'm gonna lose you just to
find my way back to you or don't ever
freaking call me what do you think i
think we're going to say lose you it's
more of an epic song so much emotion
float versus body float might be the
bigger fan favorite it was featured in
hotel transylvania 3. i don't know
exactly how that happened but it
happened the other one is a
collaboration between myself and
timbaland they're both pretty like
meaningful songs to me but being able to
work with the legends that is timbaland
perform it on stage with him i think
body has a little bit more of like wow
moment for me and then there's into you
and cavemey collaborations one with a
duo named collaz and another one with
tableau of epicy and gallant into you is
a great edm tropical song cavemen is
memorable because so many people loved
it to this day i feel like so many
people are asking for part two of the
song and i'll just throw it out there
the talks are happening we're just all
very busy all right we're almost to the
end of the first round these are so many
songs guys can't help myself first good
for you we're gonna go with good for you
i would like to think that olivia
rodrigo really was inspired by my song
good for you
good for you is one of the first songs
in korea that really took off for me it
became kind of like my theme song i feel
like i've sang this song thousands and
thousands and thousands of times it's
just a classic for not just me but for a
lot of people so good for you olivia if
you want to like smash this together
good good for for you we could have good
for you part three up to you heaven's
door verse interview i gotta go to
heaven's door the first song that i
released as an artist did i know what i
was saying when i sang it no did i
pronounce things properly hell no but it
was still my first song so it will
forever have a soft spot in my
heart between heaven's joy and good for
you honestly for me easy it's good for
you it's more representative of what i
want to do and i wrote that song kevin
store i did not write royalties are
important kids
cavemen and body i'm gonna go with
caveman it's fun to be able to say that
i have a great song with two people that
i consider to be really good friends as
great and as cool as timbaland is
between lose you and potion potion the
choreo is fun i get to pretend like i'm
drunk on stage down for you versus
oh this is kind of hard i still think
runaway so many people love that song i
don't want to get canceled by my own
fans for choosing a song that they all
love so this is out of fear um honestly
and wonder honestly
it was just a big song for me love dying
and you're sexy i'm sexy
they're so different how do you compare
the two oh man this stuff
i think we gotta go love diamond it hits
too close to home because i wrote it
just too personal of a song for me to
give up over we also have a drunk song
over here we're fine admit and come
through
i'm gonna say admit i feel like this is
like a new era of music new beginning of
musical exploration and creation for me
it's much more in line with where i want
to take my music and so today we're
going with admit now i don't know you
anymore verse lost on me
i don't know lost on me is like makes
you think of you're standing on the
beach sipping a margarita meanwhile i
don't know you anymore people love it so
much what do i do my mind and my heart
are so different right now
we're gonna go lost on me we're gonna
invest into this new baby we have eight
more songs between lost on me and admit
lost on me love diet honestly oh shoot
i love diamond runaway and potion run
away pavement and good for you good for
you it's the final four baby okay this
is really hard good for you
first run away good for you the first
song that i was able to put out that i
felt like i had a significant part in
like writing and producing the record it
was also the song that got me nominated
for best male artist at mama runaway is
a single that kind of signaled a shift
in my sound a few years ago but the one
that has more weight on me i think it's
going to be good for you lost on me and
love diana love daiyoung when i was
writing it i was in a very dark place it
was kind of a form of therapy for me
lost on me again send a single do i need
to say more it's like one of two of my
favorite songs on the entire new album
it was new in the types of sounds and
the textures and the lyrical content
that we were trying to create it's a new
starting point for me as an artist so
between the two my two little babies
drum roll please
we're going
lost on me
and then it's a final two and i think
you guys know what i'm gonna do here i
think we're gonna go with good for you
no i'm just kidding
everybody's like what we're going to go
with lost tommy
[Music]
and here is a little preview everything
about you now is bittersweet bittersweet
last song in the symphony
and there we have it we ranked how many
songs is this 32 songs and we've landed
at lost on me
check out the new album which is called
there and back again and the new single
lost on me it will not be lost on you
you're just going to really vibe with it
and you're going to love it i'm also on
tour in 51 cities as of right now you
can find everything that you want to
know probably more than you need to know
about me at ericknom.com buzzfeed thank
you for having me it's always a pleasure
i hope i never have to pick between my
children ever again everybody stay
healthy happy and safe thanks guys see
you soon
bye
[Music]
you